freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
heutigen video gemeinsam mit diemer wir
haben was cooles für euch überlegt bzw
für uns eigentlich mehr oder weniger
ihr kennt ja mein altbewährtes problem
ich bestellt zu viel essen und wenn man
viel essen bestellt dann ist es nicht
nur sehr teuer sondern es hängt einfach
irgendwann zur nase raus erst wollte ich
auch klar sage es ja langweilig wenn es
zum beispiel liebsten pizza dagegen
genau genau kratzt deshalb sehr gut dass
wir hier bei mir im büro sind mitten in
der kölner innenstadt bus unmenge an
restaurants gibt von dem man bestellen
kann und unsere aufgabe die wir uns
gegenseitig gestellt haben ist ihr
bestellen irgendwas wo wir denken der
andere hat es noch nie gegessen also es
geht darum was neues herauszufinden und
hoffentlich irgendwann geilen neuen
geschmack zu entdecken ich bin mir
sicher ich hab was ganz krass ausgesucht
ja ich hab von solisten was den kopf ich
habe schon geguckt wo ich arbeite ja wir
haben trotz aller kategorien geschaut es
gibt zum beispiel äthiopisch das habe
ich auch schon mal gesehen hat leider
dazu ich wollte eigentlich für die
militärisch bestellt aber ich würde
sagen du bist hast du darfst anfangen
such dir was oft ich habe jetzt einen
laden ausgesucht ich wollte die woanders
bestellen aber die haben zu ich habe
mich drauf gehabt führte die
öffnungszeiten sind das gilt auch
interessant und zwar habe ich nach
kategorien geschaut so was so nicht so
exotisch sein könnte
und dann haben mich persisch gesehen und
ich glaube herzlich ist ziemlich lecker
den ich mal rein ist auch eine gute
bewertung ich achte darauf bewertung
immer wichtig ich glaube dass in den
linsensuppe ist typisch ich liebe
liebenden suchen leute über alles aber
nicht alle sind gut dass das ziemlich in
der mitte hin zu bekommen wie nehme ich
glaube ich dann irgendwas von vorspeisen
vielleicht kaskaden weiß wirklich nicht
aussprechen
das klingt auch interessant ich glaube
dass das nehme mal und leicht noch
barbados ich glaube dass du musst mal
ausprobieren ok dann steht mir das mal
ab und hoffen dass es max' schmeckt so
freundlich haben etwas besonderes
rausgesucht und zwar street krisen
belgischer hof belgisch französische
küche relativ selten die einzige
challenge die ich vielleicht sähe die
man ist ja vegetarisch aber ich guck mal
was es da fein es gibt also ich will
natürlich was möglichst außergewöhnlich
bin peter chou französischer kartoffel
ziegenkäse auflauf süßkartoffel nerven
und petersilienwurzel klingt schon mal
sehr gut wir gucken aber mal ob es
vielleicht auch was andere
es gibt kennt man natürlich würde man
aber niemals bestellen würde ich
persönlich jetzt zumindest zu behaupten
müssen auch dazu noch seinen viereinhalb
sterne also wirklich sehr sehr sehr gute
bewertung lang kuchen kennt man leider
kopf das ist mehr so sandwich ich würde
sagen wir gehen auf den bisher belgische
zitronen tat mit vanille schmandt finde
ich sehr bild und dann ist dieser
französische kartoffel ziegenkäse
auflauf wirklich an exotischen ich
glaube das ist mit das krasseste was wir
da sehen würde sagen ist jetzt wirklich
flott gewesen belgische kommen ist
natürlich auch sehr verwirrt aber ich
glaube damit sind wir auf einem guten
weg 58 ich muss aber mal ein passwort
eingeben weil ich vor so kurzer zeit
erst weil die verhandlung gestellt habe
so freuen es ist soweit wir haben beide
vor uns unsere bestellung stehen die
relativ flott eigentlich nicht dein zwei
läufer schnell schneller ich bin ich zu
hause bei uns war das zumindestens nicht
unter anwesenheit ein bisschen außerhalb
das stimmt ich würde sagen die man wir
haben beide noch nicht reingeschaut wir
tauschen jetzt beim nächsten mal ein
bisschen fertig ist da ein bisschen raus
geflossen ja ich bin so gespannt wie das
finde ich schon sehr gespannt du bist
ganz kommen darf als erstes auspacken
ich bin vor allem gespannt ob du erlebt
was es ist ich schon so etwas kartoffel
iges und paprika afrika nicht so gute
nase auf ihr einmal nach oder nachspeise
monster noch nicht auf weil ein gepackt
eigentlich weiß ich das jetzt richtig
gerüstet also wenn wir uns gegenseitig
was neues bestellen und ich die
russischen stellen würden dann wenn ich
ein bisschen ich hoffe das was ich aus
dem so etwas wird nicht wo mein gott oh
mein gott also gar nicht hier ziegenkäse
jetzt auf gemüse kartoffeln oder sauce
mit erbsen dass kartoffeln ist richtig
ich bin nur sehr gespannt sieht fancy
auch oder eher weniger fans die aus und
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass es
viele kinder sein können das ist
interessant probier mal vielleicht
schmeckt uns nur mäßig rauf aber ich
kann es mir eigentlich auch nicht
vorstellen im manne gekommen da kommen
mag so gerne ziegenkäse
ich war mir nicht sicher ob das mögen
das heftig hier auch ich nehme direkt so
eine ecke mit günstigen käse essen oh
nein weil mein nachname heißt über
selbst vermutlich so sie ihren mann
kennen
was glaubst du ist eigentlich so da
steckt das heißt dass ich so ein pass
kannibalismus hier betreibe aber es ist
echt lecker ziegenkäse leute leben vor
allem so müssen um nicht drauf das
projekt oder das schmeckt diese
kartoffeln schmecken so wurde mein gott
walther mit dem ziegenkäse das ist ja
überlegen die smarts explosion die jagd
er selbst noch nicht bestellt weiß ja
übels krank ich kann nur sagen könnte
ist also ich überlegt er macht hin mit
ziegenkäse behörden bevor du fertig über
links macht vielleicht noch das ausland
gibt gibt dir das noch eine idee hätte
der abend hier oh mein gott auch noch
mit getrockneten orange darauf muss man
ein bisschen das soll der soldat ist das
protein
es ist also ein kuchen auf jeden fall
sollen wir da bekommen wir würden wir
müssen einfach mal kreuz und quer dürfte
neben davon auch eine gabe okay dann
kommt erst mal lecker ich glaube also
wahrscheinlich ist das nicht in unserer
umgebung ich würde gern noch mal mit mir
vorneweg gehen von einer anderen seite
ja immer gewollt dass sie so fluffig aus
mein gott das ist auch sehr stark
bedrohlich aber so lege ich glaube ich
lüge nicht dass es unter den top drei
sachen die ich jemals bestellt habe ich
bin glaube ich bei dir deshalb weiß doch
schnell gehen glaubt hingegen trocken
ist es noch heiß es ist noch perfekt der
rookie verbreiteten diesem zimmer
nachtisch und didaktisches anders länger
und man bildet sich vor allem ein
bisschen ein dass es so gesund ist schon
fast ne ich glaube das ist doch was
sonst noch drin war irgendwas frisch ist
in süß kartoffeln erbsen und
petersilienwurzel das ist wahrscheinlich
die wurzeln etwas war so ein bisschen
fester konsistenz hat
dafür habe ich erst vor zwei jahren für
mich entdeckt und so hat so lecker ne
also wirklich sie mal ich bin sehr sehr
überrascht von dem essen
viel hänge von dem bestellen oder du
hast sie ich glaube ich muss nicht mal
ausparken ist das geil zu essen auf
jeden fall bekommen doch glaubt man
mithalten mit dem jetzt sag mal die war
was denkst du ist das welche küche ich
muss sagen es ist jetzt nicht kein
nationalgericht also das ist eigentlich
ein bisschen schwer soweit könnte könnte
vieles sein aber der laden hat die
kategorien gab wohl ausgesucht hat
das ist ein laden der eine spezielle
küche laden das minus immer ich schätze
so etwas zu er so etwas südländisches
keine ahnung welche scharf heißt der
laden weil der behälter ist das so
lecker belgisch das einzige wie man
darauf kommen könnte ist halt der
ziegenkäse gespanns höchst das ist doch
was für medien weil ich habe mit
belgischer küche ja ich sehe also man
kennt halt nur belgische pommes kennt -
die jagd ist wächst das aus ist das noch
mit sozialer dran und wir sind so dicke
pommes und die amazone heftige
philosophie belgier sind krass was ihre
form und muss ich das probiert muss die
leute welche kraftwerke ja jetzt auch
wie man auch mal aus erstmal der
klassische beilagensalat dazu kann man
nicht viel sagen habe ich gar nicht mit
bestellen ist korrekt
weil dafür geld wird aber in der jedoch
auch mit diesen kirschtomaten ich bin
sehr geschockt zu sein könnte was aber
auch rein gönnen ich glaube dass auch
diese art küche die einen goldenen
leistung große mengen die fast etwas
davon dass spezielle das was davon
weiteres normale willst du was jeder
kennt sagt ich finde ich einfach sein
das zu erraten
dallas sid erst mal aus wie fladenbrot
okay das ist was grund wurde das ist
quasi fladenbrot zudem gelegt was runter
womit fange ich an also hier erstmal das
kenne ich von so abstürzt man kriegt so
brot für eine ganze familie oder sieht
das nicht sehr lecker aus es riecht auch
sehr lecker so frisch gebacken was zu
fladenbrot mag ich gerne mal das ist als
normal ist auch nicht so dieses ich
kenne so fladenbrot was man so bekommen
das ist dann schon so hart aber das ist
noch sehr häufig kommt dann hat auch
diese plätze selbst ihr geliebter somit
ab
sehr lecker sehr sehr gut dafür thomas
habermann auf dem tisch was haben wir
jetzt hier find ich habe mir vermutung
was das sein könnte
ich habe gedacht es sei also safranreis
welcher allerdings erwartet ehrlich
gesagt ich dachte ich dass das hier drin
ist weil sie so vettel
der antrag ist das schön ist so mächtig
sein könnte ich finde das ist schon
ziemlich offensichtlich also ja es ist
noch suppe da etwa was das für eine art
to basics
jetzt kommen die bekannten kartoffel das
haben wir hier das ist wirklich sehr
fertig auf jeden fall
es ist nicht mehr lange was aubergine
stimmt das du kannst die kamera wieder
ablegen ich wahrscheinlich für die leute
wird mal hefti sieht es aus das habe ich
noch nie probiert selber und dass leute
meine lieblings als was soll ich sagen
ich hatte angst noch so einfach so
persisches essen bestellt hast oder so
aber jetzt glaube ich etwas kann gut
sein dass werth ist aber ich kenne also
bist du spielst du sonst was dieses brot
kommen hier auch vom persischen
restaurants bekannt war aber das kenne
ich gar nicht ich probier's sofort mir
diese suppe
aber ich bin so gespannt wie das
schmeckt weil ja mal dass ich wäre
verrückt es ist dass kann ich auch ich
mag mir so bekannt vor
das bewusst zu kennen wenn du kein
fleisch isst dann ist das eine sehr gute
sehr gute alternative um b12 und solche
sachen zu bekommen
nicht ganz so dass du nach was ist das
halt ich bin absolut nein nein das ist
da sie wird folgt das ist eine
linsensuppe linsen wenn du beim türken
bis allgemein sehr viel fleisch und
werde ich mir geht es dabei in summe ist
für mich eine der längsten sachen
überhaupt ich würde nachsalzen aber ich
werde immer auch ein bisschen wenig salz
aber ich mag dieses linsen nächsten wie
ich weiß nichts beschreiben soll ist
also ganz speziellen geschmack
sehr lecker was hat so ein bisschen wie
originale holen muss das hat so eine
tallinn oder irgendwas was so ein
bisschen so eine bittere twitter
bissigkeit haben im abgang
aber ich mache auch ganz gerne das ja
ich hauptsächlich genau ob ich da
braucht noch zusatz geschmäckern ja das
schmeckt aber so denke ich glaube dass
iris auberginen probierte ich für diesen
motor ist es mit sehr über silber
gedruckt und aber sehr sehr lecker auch
erst richtig ja okay dann habe ich mehr
oder weniger erraten auf jeden fall was
für ein geiles video wir haben ja so ein
festmahl was wir uns rein werden können
und notebook leute sehr gute video.de
von mir gewesen ich bin sehr froh dass
ich es gemacht habe dass er gerne wieder
sehen vom nächsten video wieder macht's
gut und bis dahin tschüss